hey do you have a favorite reality show
oh come on don't lie everyone has one dr
cleff loves some american ninja warrior
and i've got it on good authority that
dr bright can't get enough of the
bachelor so how about you huh do you
obsessively follow the romantic highs
and lows of love island or are you more
of the type who likes to curl up with a
mug of hot cocoa and enjoy a nice
wholesome episode of the great british
baking show do you ever yell at the tv
when the contestants on jeopardy just
can't get the answer right do you get a
kick out of seeing what crazy
collectibles will show up on this week's
episode of pawn stars if you answered
yes to any of these you're not alone
millions of people around the world
still tune in to all kinds of reality tv
personally i just can't get enough of my
favorite hidden camera show laugh is fun
what's that you've never heard of laugh
is fun
oh boy you're really missing out if you
like reality tv you're going to love
laugh is fun laugh is fun also known as
scp-2030 isn't a show that you can watch
on tv instead it appears as the most
popular form of media distribution in
the current year today you can find it
on file sharing and streaming websites
but in the 2000s you could rent it from
the dvd kiosk at the mall and back in
the 90s it used to show up as multi-tape
sets in video rental stores even though
the scp foundation has only been aware
of laphis fun since 1993 it has a
recorded 38 seasons as of 2014 meaning
that it may have existed in some form as
far back as the
1970s if you want to binge all 38
seasons you might also want to look it
up under the names laugh is life or in
some countries laugh is laugh and if you
happen to be in a country where laugh is
laugh isn't available you may want to
try changing your location using a vpn
to one where you can access it oh what's
that
you don't have a vpn service well then
i'm glad you're here because before we
go any further i have a very important
word from our sponsor who just so
happens to be nordvpn the preferred vpn
service of all the researchers here at
scp explained sign up now at nordvpn.com
forward slash scp explained nordvpn
isn't just a vpn it's truly the best vpn
available with a simple click you'll be
able to access content that might be
blocked just because of your location so
you'll never have to miss an episode of
your favorite anomalous television
programs but wait there's more much much
more what if you're right in the middle
of binge watching of season 31 when
suddenly your quality dips to looking
like a couple of blurry blocks or
fighting over an old shoebox
never fear because nordvpn encrypts all
of your traffic that means your internet
service provider can't throttle your
service and slow down your streaming
speed you should never settle for less
than the highest quality pixels after
all and it doesn't matter how you choose
to watch nordvpn is available on every
modern platform including windows ios
android mac os linux and even android tv
the monthly cost is the same as a cup of
coffee regular coffee that is not the
kind that comes from scp-294
and if you sign up by going to
nordvpn.com forward slash scp explained
you'll even get a free month so go try
it for yourself right now that's
nordvpn.com forward slash scp explained
now back to your regularly scheduled
programming as we were saying laugh is
fun is a prank show that puts unknowing
everyday people into ridiculous
scenarios and films their reactions each
episode is about 10 to 12 minutes long
and features an opening and closing
monologue from beloved supposedly human
tv presenter laffy mclafferson aka
scp-2030-1
you've probably seen him before he's
never seen without his blue three-piece
suit and black wingtip shoes funniest
guy on tv seriously i think he should
replace james corden on the late late
show and maybe even take up hosting a
gig on snl if he's still got time after
he had this amazing monologue at the end
of an episode in season 32.
what a ride uh folks we've seen printers
that eat eaters that print and
everything in between makes you
appreciate the old clunker you have at
the back office doesn't it no printers
may not always work when you want or
need them to but they sure make for some
excellent comedy and that's what we're
all about here comedy we're here to make
you laugh we hope you laughed thank you
for laughing with us that's what we're
about here doesn't it folks come laugh
with us again next time and remember
laugh is
fun
good night and laugh and laugh just
laugh we love the make laugh make more
for laughter so as two for laugh laugh
with us laugh with us laugh with us
laugh with us laugh with us laugh with
us laugh laugh laugh laugh and let us in
i couldn't tell you what his face looks
like though because he's always framed
from the neck down once the pranks are
done for the episode he'll step up on
that bright yellow stage and deliver his
closing monologue which always ends with
a pan over the audience as everyone
chants laugh with us then the show
always just cuts to black the closest
thing the show ever has to credits is a
title card that says filmed in front of
a studio audience in partnership with
ywtgthft
for a show that doesn't advertise or
even air on tv laugh is fun is still a
beloved classic and when you watch it
it's easy to see why it's been around so
long laffy and the team pull off some
really classic pranks on laugh his laugh
there's this one episode in season 13
where an unsuspecting family is sitting
down to dinner father starts choking and
the family reacts with horror until
suddenly a pair of slits appear on the
father's neck allowing him to breathe
those slits soon become nostrils and
before you know it a full second head
grows out of his neck that head then
grows its own neck which grows a noose
then a face then another head then
another neck this keeps happening a
total of 18 times while the rest of the
family looks on in horror but don't
worry before things go too far laffy
pops out from under the table and tells
the family their on laugh is fun laffy
points out the cameras and the whole
family starts laughing including all 18
of the father's heads there's also
another great season 13 episode called
squirrels oh man okay this one had me in
stitches alright so there's this couple
lying in bed and the wife wakes up
because she hears this squeaking noise
she taps her husband on the shoulder to
wake him up but she draws her hand back
in horror because she can feel something
moving under her husband's skin so
before she can ask if he's okay boom
hundreds of squirrels explode out of his
skin and start running around the room
while the wife screams then laffy walks
in and turns the lights on accompanied
by the husband who is perfectly okay
even though he's been skinned from head
to toe everyone laughs alright then
there's the most recent episode from
season 24 called swelling there's this
old lady sitting on a park bench feeding
the pigeons and a couple walks past her
when they walk past the old lady gets
swarmed by the pigeon she's feeding the
pigeons force themselves into her mouth
and keeps swarming until her stomach
cavity bursts open the couple who gets
sprayed with guts as the all the pigeons
fly off are extremely distressed by this
until laffy shows up some people say
that this episode is too similar to
squirrels and that the show was starting
to get stale at this point but i think
the joke is unique enough to stand on
its own plus with a prank show as long
running as laugh it's inevitable that
you're going to see some jokes get
reused really it's not about the prank
itself it's about the reactions of the
people which are always priceless and
man the way that laffy mclafferson comes
into the frame by climbing out of the
old lady's open rib cage i was rolling
on the floor now you don't think the old
animal's exploding out of peoplebit is
funny
okay that's fair enough ah let me think
what are some of my other favorite
episodes of life is fun oh yes the
margaret thatcher episode from season
21. that's another great thing about
laugh is fun it's not afraid to get a
little political so this woman walks
into her kitchen and opens the cabinet
but instead of the food being in there
it's just a big blob of flesh the flesh
blob rolls out onto the counter and
morphs into a misshapen caricature of
margaret thatcher with a
disproportionately big head the woman
starts screaming but the thatcher
creature jumps onto her pinning her down
and shoving its tongue into her mouth
the deeper the tongue goes the more
margaret thatcher faces start appearing
all over the woman's skin all the faces
start reciting thatcher's april 1986
speech on the bombing of libya in
perfect unison you might watch it and
think the woman's going to choke based
on how long the creature's tongue is
down her throat but good old laffy comes
in and the studio audience goes nuts
laffy points out to the cameras and says
your on laugh is fun and the woman
starts laughing too with the creature's
tongue still in her mouth but i think my
favorite prank i've ever seen on laugh
is fun was the one from season 37 so
it's in a hospital there's a woman
getting a c-section and all the doctors
are gathered around one of the doctors
makes a comment on how much hair the
baby has and then he screams and drops
his surgical tools the rest of the team
all starts screaming as well and then
this is where it gets really funny you
see ryan seacrest's head pop up from out
of the woman
okay so this is causing her a lot of
pain obviously so she starts screaming
and crying as the ryan seacrest head
fully emerges at which point you can
tell that its head is on an octopus body
classic bait and switch right but that's
not the end the ryan seacrest octopus
starts singing row row row your boat as
it emerges and then three more octopi
with celebrities heads come out of this
woman there's one that looks like jack
nicholson one that looks like johnny
cash and one who looks like martin
freeman and when they've all come out of
her they start singing together in four
part harmony it's hilarious laffy walks
in to point out the cameras and all the
doctors start laughing even the woman on
the operating table is laughing in fact
she laughs so hard she passes out it's a
real shame that there are never any end
credits because it would be so cool to
find out more about the people who make
this show i mean they're total comedic
geniuses and special effects wizards too
i couldn't even guess how they do some
of those pranks but sadly there's very
little information about the show online
and you can't even ask the victims of
the pranks about it because all of them
are dead what no no no no not because of
laugh is fun that's just a prank show
it's all jokes they always show everyone
laughing and perfectly okay at the end
no matter how badly they got mutilated
in the episode you can even see some
people who have been on previous
episodes among the studio audiences if
you look hard enough but okay by total
coincidence everyone who is featured on
laugh is fun eventually dies or is
already dead of totally unrelated causes
like the turman family dad gary turman
was the one who had 18 extra heads grow
out of his neck gary his wife lindsay
and their two kids tragically passed
away in a car wreck on the 28th of april
1989. melissa and travis younglin the
couple from the squirrel prank went
missing and were last seen on the 12th
of may 1989. the couple from the pigeon
prank macy gershon and kyle parker were
both killed by a hit-and-run driver in
september of 2000. doris carter the
woman from the thatcher prank passed
away from ovarian cancer in 1997 and
rebecca nash the woman who gave birth to
all those singing celebrity cephalopods
died in childbirth in 2013. you might
think that the last one had something to
do with her laugh is fun episode due to
the hospital connection but the
surgeon's present when she died didn't
report anything strange happening at the
time all these deaths happen in roughly
the same years that all these people had
their appearances on laugh but it's
because it's only available on streaming
and video it can't really be said what
the connection is since there aren't any
air dates for any of the episodes while
you might assume that these people died
after their appearances on laugh and the
show is actually some kind of death
curse it's just as likely that they died
before and laugh as fun is somehow
filmed and distributed from the great
beyond some people even think that the
people who film laugh actually kidnap
all the people who appear on the show
and fake their deaths in some kind of
big sinister conspiracy sure i have
heard that all the people who supposedly
died after being on the show have
inconsistencies in their death records
and that many of their graves actually
just hold empty coffins but still that
feels totally unrealistic to me i mean
come on can you really picture tv's own
laffy lafferson kidnapping anyone he has
such a friendly attitude like i said
before no information whatsoever exists
about the way this show is made not even
the scp foundation has any answers
they're still actively investigating the
ways in which people get chosen to be on
laugh as fun as well as where it's
filmed and who produces it talk about a
really niche cult hint i hope i've sold
you on laugh is fun it may not be that
well known and you might have trouble
finding it but trust me it's the
funniest prank show you'll probably ever
watch i guarantee once you get into it
it'll make you laugh and laugh and laugh
laugh with us laugh with us
laugh with us
laugh with us and hey if you want to
laugh with us in other videos check out
robot battle royale scp-1370 pesterbot
and a c-snails fantasy
scp-1867 a gentleman for more of the
funnier side of the scp foundation